regardez maintenant une petite séquence
elle date d'il n'y a pas longtemps elle
est sans commentaire c'était cette
semaine en corise le président de la
République était là-bas en déplacement
et le président du Conseil général se
devait d' être mise en image Guillaume
Daré à tout de
suite je vous demande de regarder
devant et de faire que 2012 soit une
date dont on se souvienne comme
quelque amusement de ma part à voir
Nicolas Sarkozi mettre ses pas dans ce
de jaesirac il n pas la même
pointure comment ça va allez bien bien
ENF quand on vient en cor ce n'est
jamais innocents parce que c'est un lieu
où on forme les présidentsil est venu
cor pas pour me faire de la promotion
c'est pour la sienne François